now I'm a meteorologist by degree I have
a bachelors masters and PhD in physical
meteorology so I'm a meteorologist and
so with that comes four questions always
this is one prediction I will always get
right and those questions are marshal
what channel are you on dr. Shephard
what's the weather gonna be tomorrow and
oh I love this one my daughter is
getting married next September it's an
outdoor wedding is it gonna rain not
kidding I get those and I don't know the
answer just the science isn't there but
the one I get a lot these days is a
shepherd do you believe in climate
change do you believe in global warming
now I have to gather myself every time I
get that question because this is an
ill-posed question science isn't a
belief system my son he's ten he
believes in the tooth fairy and he needs
to get over that because I'm losing
dollars fast but he believes in the
tooth fairy but consider this Bank of
America building there in Atlanta
you never hear anyone say do you believe
if you go to the top of that building
and throw a ball off it's going to fall
you never hear that because gravity is a
thing so why don't we hear the question
do you believe in gravity but of course
we hear the question do you believe in
global warming well consider these facts
the American Association for the
Advancement of science triple-a as one
of the leading organizations in science
queried scientists and the public on
different science topics here are some
of them genetically modified foods
animal research human evolution and look
at what the scientists say of
those the people that actually study
those topics in red versus the grey with
the public things how did we get there
how did we get there that scientists in
public are so far apart on these science
issues well I'll come a little bit
closer to home for me
climate change 87% of scientists believe
that humans are contributing to climate
change but only 50% of the public how do
we get there so it begs the question
what shapes perceptions about science
it's an interesting question and one
that I've been thinking about quite a
bit I think that one thing that shapes
perceptions in the public about science
is belief systems and biases belief
systems and biases go with me for a
moment because I want to talk about
three elements of that confirmation bias
dunning-kruger effect and cognitive
dissonance
now these sound like big fancy academic
terms and they are but when I describe
them you're gonna be like oh I recognize
that I even know somebody that does that
confirmation bias finding evidence that
supports what we already believe that
we're probably all a little bit guilty
of that at times take a look at this I'm
on Twitter and often when it snows I'll
get this tweet back to me
hey dr. Shepherd I have 20 inches of
global warming in my yard what are you
guys talking about climate change
I get that tweet a lot actually it's a
cute tweet it makes me chuckle as well
but it's oh so fundamentally
scientifically flawed because it
illustrates that the person tweeting
doesn't understand the difference
between weather and climate I often say
weather is your mood and climate is your
personality think about that weather is
your mood climate is your personality
your mood today doesn't necessarily tell
me anything about your personality nor
does a cold day tell me anything about
climate change or a hot day for that
matter dunning-kruger two scholars from
Cornell came up with the dunning-kruger
effect if you go look up the peer review
paper for this you will see all kinds of
fancy terminology
it's an illusory superiority complex
thinking we know things in other words
people think they know more than they do
or they underestimate what they don't
know and then there's cognitive
dissonance cognitive dissonance is
interesting we just recently had
Groundhog Day
right now there's no better definition
of cognitive dissonance than intelligent
people asking me if a rodents forecast
is accurate but I get that all of the
time but I also hear about the Farmers
Almanac up on the Farmers Almanac people
are familiar with it the problem is it's
so much about 37% accurate according the
studies at Penn State University but
we're in an era of science where we
actually can forecast the weather and
believe it or not and I know something
like that all right we're about 90
percent accurate or more with weather
forecasts you just tend to remember the
occasional miss you do so confirmation
bias dunning-kruger in cognitive
distance I think those shape
biases and perceptions that people have
about science but then there's literacy
and misinformation that keep us boxed in
as well during the hurricane season of
2017 media outlets had to actually
assign reporters to dismiss fake
information about the weather forecast
that's the era that we're in I deal with
this all the time in social media
someone will tweet a forecast that's a
forecast for Hurricane Irma but here's
the problem it didn't come from the
Hurricane Center but people were
tweeting and sharing this it went viral
it didn't come from the National
Hurricane Center at all so I I spent 12
years of my career at NASA before coming
to the University of Georgia and I chair
the earth science advisory committee was
just up there last week in DC and I saw
some really interesting things here's a
nasa model and science data from
satellites showing the 2017 hurricane
season you see Harvey Hurricane RV there
look at all the dust coming off of
Africa look at the wildfires up in
Northwest US and in Western Canada there
comes hurricane
Irma this is fascinating to me but
admittedly I'm a weather geek but more
importantly it illustrates that we have
the technology to not only observe the
weather and climate system but predict
it there's scientific understanding so
there's no need for some of those
perceptions and biases that we've been
talking about we have knowledge but
think about this this is hissed in Texas
after hurricane Harvey now I write a
contribution for Forbes magazine
periodically and I wrote an article a
week before hurricane Harvey made
landfall Fang there's probably gonna be
40 to 50 inches of rainfall
I wrote that a week before it happened
but yet when you talk to people in
Houston people were saying we had no
idea was going to be this bad I'm just a
week before but I know it's amusing but
the reality is we all struggle with
perceiving something outside of our
sphere
it's level people in Houston get rain
all of the time they flood all of the
time but they've never experienced that
Houston gets about 34 inches of rainfall
for the entire year they got 50 inches
in three days that's an anomaly event
that's outside of the normal so belief
systems and biases literacy and
misinformation how do we step out of the
boxes that are cornering our perceptions
well we don't even have to go to Houston
we can come very close to home remember
snowpocalypse Snowmageddon snowzilla
whatever you want to call it all two
inches of it two inches of snow shut the
city of Atlanta down but the reality is
we were in a winter storm watch we went
to a winter weather advisory and a lot
of people perceive that as being a
downgrade oh it's not going to be as bad
when in fact that wasn't the perception
was that it was not going to be as bad
but it was actually an upgrade things
were getting worse as the models were
coming in so that's an example of how we
get boxed in by our perceptions so the
question becomes how do we expand our
radius the area of a circle is PI R
squared we increase the radius Winkies
crease the area how do we expand our
radius of understanding about science
here my thoughts
you take inventory of your own biases
and I'm challenging you all to do that
take an inventory of your own biases
where do they come from your upbringing
your political perspective your faith
what shapes your own biases then
evaluate your sources where do you get
your information on science where do you
read what do you listen to just consume
your information on science and then
it's important to speak out talk about
how you evaluated your biases and
evaluating your sources now I want you
to listen to this little 40 second clip
from
one of the top TV meteorologists in the
u.s. Greg Fischer in the raleigh-durham
area he's revered in that region but he
was a climate skeptic but listen to what
he says about speaking out there I was
making and didn't realize it until very
recently was that I was only looking for
information to support what I already
thought and was not interested in
listening to anything contrary and so I
woke up one morning and there was this
question in my mind about Greg are you
engaging in confirmation bias are you
only looking for information to support
what you already think and if I was
honest with myself and I tried to be I
admitted that's that was going on and so
the more I talked to scientists and read
peer-reviewed literature and tried to
conduct myself the way I have been
taught to conduct myself at Penn State
when I was a student it became very
difficult for me to make the argument
that we weren't at least having some
effect maybe there was still a doubt as
to how much but to say nothing was was
not a responsible thing for me to do as
a scientist or a person
Greg fishel just talked about expanding
his radius of understanding of science
and when we expand our radius it's not
about making a better future but it's
about preserving life as we know it so
as we think about expanding our own
radius and understanding science it's
critical for Athens Georgia for Atlanta
Georgia for the state of Georgia and for
the world so expand your radius thank
you
[Applause]